have you ever accepted anyone as a patient or a member without a full diagnosis?
Did they answer it? Yes, but because we don't diagnose and because we don't treat disease.
So we don't, we're not like a clinic that that treats disease and and so therefore we don't
um um that's not what we worry about so we still we still care for a person and make recommendations
based upon the cheeks who are not based on their diagnosis. Now if we're going to do
rife programming um you know it's very helpful if we have a diagnosis so we don't want to program
but even if we have a suspicion of a disease you can run it. It's just like when you use the
rife machine and you have a really bad cold well you might not go in and get an x-ray to find out
whether you have pneumonia um but you can run the pneumonia blaster program because you have the
signs and the symptoms um on the disease so do you need to go and get uh stamped rubber stamp
of a disease in order to treat um for the signs and the symptoms so you could use your brain and go
boy I have this really bad cold and cough so I get to run this respiratory thing I think it's a virus
I get to run by viral program I think it's a bacterial infection I get to run that so you can still
treat um the person that you're treating your body um not necessarily treating a name diagnosis.
The question that came in I'm regretting allowing the doctor to put a tag into my dress tissue they don't
make it sound like you have a choice but a thing to do I've heard subsequently that some women
have reactions to the medals and the tags if I had to do it again I would not allow it they
assured me it was harmless but we know how that goes yeah we know how that goes they assured a lot
of people that they'd be fine going in with COVID and getting red decibel we don't have that um you know
the tissue it's really hard to trust the medical profession with all the lies that have
about it all the medical professionals who have compromised their integrity the last few years
like never before it's very hard to trust them um now firstly I have not heard of a lot of people having
serious effects from that tag however however we don't I mean baby comparison has passed the
stage of cancer they've recovered they're doing really well but now they're getting headaches
what's it from however years ago I had a young woman she was in her 20s came in with serious headaches
um I had a testitor with kinesiology and she came up with a copper toxicity so I think you okay where
did you get this copper toxicity so we went through all the possible sources of copper etc etc and
turned out she was oh my gosh I just had a copper IUD placed a month ago and that's when my headache
started um so she went and had it taken out uh at her headaches went away after we did some detox on
it so you know the practice of medicine is can be the cause of a lot of disorders not even disease but
just you know issues that a person may have signs symptoms that a person could have so yeah uh what
else they don't trust anything they do even though we need them they're beneficial for all sorts of
you know crisis intervention broken legs etc but um it's uh it's hard to trust them